well she was charged with harassment
against a 59 year old woman called
michelle merritt today as you say 56
year old mp for leicester east has
been found guilty this was a case that
was about a series of calls that had
been made to the 59 year old woman the
prosecution said that claudia webb the
mp had been jealous of miss merritt's
relationship with her partner and that
she had harassed her continued to call
her on one occasion threatened her with
acid and threatened to send nude
pictures of miss merritt to her
daughters now this was something that
claudia webb had denied
she her case for the defense was that
this was about covid that as an mp she
felt she had a responsibility to make
sure that her partner had not been
meeting with miss merrick during a
pandemic she told the prosecuting
barrister today that she this is miss
merritt was committing a crime i was
pointing this out i am the victim but
this was not something that the chief
magistrate today accepted as i say he
did find her guilty of one count of
harassment giving that summing up he
said that her evidence was vague and
inconsistent at some points he thought
it had been made up on the spare of the
moment and that her explanation he said
was frankly incredible well she has been
released on bail she'll be back here in
november for sentencing at westminster
magistrates call